de plus une innocente une femme
policière a été lâchement assassinés et
qu'au fond les gouvernants depuis bien
longtemps et particulièrement ceux qui
nous gouvernent aujourd'hui font preuve
d'une forme de lâcheté ou de soumission
à la fatalité
sur la question du terrorisme et de la
sécurité est ce que je veux dire aux
français c'est qu'il existe en france
au delà de la pensée unités de cette
classe politique des élus qui en ont
marre de cette politique de laxisme et
de lâcheté et qu'il existe des mesures
fortes courageuses que nous pourrons
mettre en oeuvre si nous venons en aux
responsables il veut donc dire que vous
les républicains vous avez déjà un
contre-projet dans les tiroirs
oui avec christian jacob avec damien
abad avec bruno retailleau avec nos deux
groupes parlementaires depuis 2010 est
nous travaillons chaque semaine à faire
des propositions au gouvernement et nous
continuerons dans les jours qui viennent
à faire ces propositions nous demandons
au gouvernement d'écouter les
oppositions quelle est ce contre-projet
il repose d'abord sur un triple constat
qu'attendent les français la preuve la
première chose c'est d'oser dire la
vérité il y a un lien entre
l'immigration massive et le terrorisme
deuxièmement le laxisme pénale dans
notre pays il n'y a pas suffisamment de
décision judiciaire forte au lendemain
d'actes répréhensibles
enfin mais c'était déjà évoqué en
introduction une soumission incroyable à
la repentance à la ddt ex construction
de notre histoire à la culpabilisation
de ceux qui nous dirigent
ce qui exaspère les français et nous
avec eux c'est que chaque jour on a des
dates différentes qui bouge et qui
change et donc à la seconde où vous
aurez un chef une méthode un calendrier
une souplesse et du pragmatisme un appui
sur les territoires et puis surtout une
campagne de vaccination massive et des
doses qui arrivent alors